so going back to shock value versus
wanting to sort of appear like the
perfect whatever and has done everything
right and wants to only present that
image to the world what do you have to
say in terms of pitching stories I think
the main advantage of the personal story
and as I say like I definitely feel I
understand what is the framework of your
personal story don't ramble don't go on
how does as I say it served the story
and what does it say about you as as the
writer and be careful not to ramble and
the advantage is that I remember and I'm
gonna tell you the same goes for me I
had a executive producer Maura Kurland
who I had worked with on medium and
she's been on a gazillion shows and she
said to me when I'm interviewing 20 to
30 writers in a day for a staffing
position what I remember are the
personal stories so that's your
advantage you could be cautious and
inaccessible and not get the job or you
could understand the right personal
story to tell when and make an impact
and knowing that that's the right
personal story and when to tell it is
that something that's refined over time
when you can kind of see somebody wince
and be like oh I think I've crossed the
line even though this really is my story
yeah I can tell I've scared them away I
think I definitely think there are areas
like when we look at what we talked
about like rape like incest like eating
disorder I think that if you think about
what is the emotional truth that came
out the other side of that
and you frame it and that I went through
a trauma that led me to this belief or
this negative narrative or and and
through that I came up with this idea
without having to define what it was
that makes you uncomfortable and you
fear will make the other person
uncomfortable so I think really what we
all want to know is something happened
to you that gave you something to say
and how does what that something is
serve your story
you